you guys I think it done a good job of
just being super data-driven maybe talk
a little bit about how I tribe you guys
are using data how it you know affects
the decisions you make and how you guys
are using that once you make an
investment to support the companies yeah
so I think there's a couple of ways to
answer that question there you know one
is people use the word data-driven where
I'm really a verse that and because it
just means that you're just gonna go
like you're not gonna be you're not
gonna think about what this data means
in the first place and so we like to use
the word data informed internally and so
we came out with this framework called
the eight ball where it was essentially
how do we quantify a product market fit
for any company that uses software or is
enabled by technology in some way and
you know the the reason we had that was
it's it's a kind of financial accounting
right if you if you look at a statement
of cash flow or balance sheet
you know P&L etc these are standardized
frameworks that were invented in the
late 1800s to help guide you on what are
the transparent things that you want to
look at for a company before you dig in
deeper so if you if you looked at a
financial accounting statement there's a
very good chance that you won't be
interested
based on the financials right like
they're you might say no like you're
nodding your head saying like yeah like
that company doesn't feel healthy to me
so I'm just gonna pass them and look on
to the next thing however if you if you
find something that's interesting say
like you know this the way in which this
company has cash management or
efficiency or you know overall their
overall cash flow in nature oh maybe I
should dig in deeper and you start doing
your work from there then you start
thinking about demand signals what does
the overall what does it her customer
base look like was the recurring nature
of it with them what does the margin
structure look like if it's lower is
there as a market big enough is a volume
large enough where they can get to a
certain scale you start asking these
bigger questions about different
industries but then you're able to
compare multiple companies to each other
by using this and then digging deeper
but you know what in the private more
it's one of the issues has always been
how do you do that what are the
standardized frameworks that you use ken
can you actually measure it and
financial statements don't work as well
for early-stage mostly because those are
all lagging indicators so if you're if
you're investing in a seed plus or
Series A or series that a lot of these
companies have really de minimis revenue
or revenue that's really not gonna paint
its picture yeah and that's coming later
and so you're looking at forms of demand
or engagement which is what I call it CF
standard a frameworks for that and
that's really where we spent almost all
of our time now you can take that in
sick it great you can actually do more
the more data you have you can do more
of that for even later stage companies
and we do that as well because investors
typically kind of what I'd say regress
to the mean is I just go back to the
finances and say hey they said they're
gonna do this but I don't see it
reflected in the finances sure but you
could have said that for Facebook Airbnb
uber at some point because you know
Google at some points well like you
would never really understand how these
businesses work unless you could look at
what we call the software ledger and
that's understanding the demand signals
for how a company works so our framework
was called the eight ball we published
this you know about six years ago my
partner done this he had published this
actually even while he was at Facebook
and you know if you're coming into
Facebook today as a product manager you
read this if you are learning product
market fit quantitatively like what are
the frameworks that you use at Stanford
they reflect our work you go to sequoias
website they have a section for product
market fit it links back to our work
because we created a standardized
framework to understand product market
fit for a company at a certain lifecycle
and and that's what we do really well is
to just get those frameworks out for
ourselves and we have a ton of software
to help automate that we have a ton of
software that stores all this for every
company we've ever seen so we can get
better at better at not just evaluating
but giving this insights and feedback
back to the company
like if you're a founder and you're
starting a company the first question
you ask everyone is like what does it
take to raise a serious seed what does
it take to raise a Series A
what does it take to raise a serious B
what are the milestones I need to
achieve and we basically say here the
[ __ ] milestones that you need to
achieve and it's and here's the
gradients of where you need to be in and
and here's what you suppose these really
look like and what people are gonna
gauge you on and this is what we tell
our entrepreneurs this is where we think
we can help but more importantly because
it's standardized this is where this is
a standardized framework you can use to
reflect back to the market as well and
so we use this as a foundation to
understand where a company is that as as
its life cycle and then what it's gonna
take to scale like what you know is this
gonna take 20 million 50 million 80
million sub subsidization of venture
capital or the source of capital get us
to certain sizes skills so what venture
capital is all about right which is that
the velocity of growth is what people
are trying to invest in I think a lot of
people kind of forget that right is it
it's a sub linear path is it super
linear or is it just linear and all
companies have different different
stages and and at some point I'm sure
we'll talk about network effect because
we both also come from that same
background but that's just as important
right is that you can only really think
about network effect if you have a
foundation to understand where a company
is in its lifecycle and do they have
product market fit or not you know
frankly most products don't have product
market fit that's what you want to know
do you want to spend your time as a
founder on something that's not working
and in my opinion if I knew that earlier
on OC I wouldn't want to have done those
10 things I would want to only focus on
the two that started working because it
had product market fit